[Musik]
bewahren, schützen und verteidigen, dienen,
schützen und verteidigen, die Verfassung
der Vereinigten Staaten, die Verfassung
der Vereinigten Staaten, so hilf mir Gott, so hilf
mir, Gott
[Musik]
genau
unsere Verpflichtung zu erkennen, die wir haben,
hier ist der Präsident, er spricht über
unsere Souveränität  Sprechen Sie über die
Souveränität einer souveränen Nation, die
die Rechte ihrer Bürger schützt, die Sie
gerade in einem Vorschauinterview gehört haben,
und das ist meiner Meinung nach das Problem für die
Vereinigten Staaten im 21
Unsere Wahl
während des Zyklus 2016 Sie haben es mit
Absicht gemacht Sie haben es mit Raffinesse gemacht
Sie haben es mit überwältigender Leistung gemacht
Lassen Sie mich zunächst sagen, dass
es die Ehre Ihres Lebens war, hier zu sein
und avenged
[Musik] zu vertreten,
und dies ist offensichtlich eine schwierige
Situation  rein, aber ihr kommt alle
zusammen und trefft als Team eine Entscheidung,
dass ihr illegal aufhört, aber
wenn ihr weiter leckt,
werde ich f  ärgern Sie alle, es ist nur
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Ich denke, manchmal können wir
den Tatsachen nicht zustimmen. Dies war das größte Publikum
, das jemals Zeuge einer Einweihungsanhörung wurde.
Können Sie aufhören
, die Fragen anderer Leute zu unterbrechen? Hey Jonathan,
jemand stellt eine Frage, es ist nicht
Ihre Pressekonferenz
Julie stellt eine Frage, wer
bitte,
großer Unterschied zwischen ehrlichen
Fehlern und absichtlicher Irreführung des
amerikanischen Volkes etwas, das regelmäßig passiert,
man kann nicht sagen, ich bin noch nicht fertig, man
kann nicht
[Musik],
bevor wir mit den offiziellen Geschäften
dieser Convention beginnen, würde ich  Nehmen Sie sich gerne einen
Moment Zeit, um die gefallenen
Polizisten in Baton Rouge, Dallas und
anderswo zu erkennen. Die
meisten Amerikaner wissen nicht, was passiert,
wenn wir einen unserer Soldaten, Seeleute,
Flieger, Marines, Küstenwache, im Kampf verlieren,
also lassen Sie mich Ihnen sagen, was passiert,
wenn Sie es sich ansehen  Diese Kabinettskandidaten
wurden aus einem bestimmten Grund ausgewählt, und das
ist die Dekonstruktion der Art und Weise, wie die
progressive Linke läuft, dass sie c
Wenn sie es nicht durchbringen, werden sie nur
irgendeine Art von Regulierung in einer
Behörde einführen, die alles ist, was wir einmal in einer
Generation haben, um etwas wirklich Großes zu tun.
Präsident Trump hat die Steuerreform zu
einer Priorität gemacht, und wir haben eine
Der republikanische Kongress, der ihn dazu bringen will, hat
mich am Sonntagnachmittag angerufen. Ich war oben in
Connecticut. Ich habe gerade mit dem
Tennis gespielt und ich dachte, er würde
mich anrufen, um mich rauszuwerfen, weil ich
ein Problem hatte, bei dem
ich heute einen Anruf vom
Präsidenten der Vereinigten Staaten erhalten habe  kurz
nach Mittag von der Air Force One und
habe auch mit dem Stabschef des Weißen Hauses,
Kelly, gesprochen, um sicherzustellen, dass wir
Klarheit über die
gestrigen Tage haben. David Ich bin fast
jeden Tag bei ihm, wenn Sie über einige
der ernstesten Angelegenheiten sprechen  Angesichts
der komplexen Probleme Amerikas und der Welt ist der
Präsident engagiert
[Musik]